one two three four five six seven she is
not gonna set herself up for failure
you're one tough lady Monica Aldama but
beneath that stone-cold exterior is a
heart of gold that loves to cheer
everybody could use a coach like you you
push people to be the best versions of
themselves if you're hard on them it's
only because you don't want their
potential to go to waste
coach Monica we're not surprised that
you've reprised your role as the Nefario
cheerleading coach you love what you do
and you're amazing at it too no wonder
you were inducted into the Navarro
College Athletic Hall of Fame we all
know what Monica dama is up to she's
doing what she does best preparing her
team for the NCAA Championships in
Daytona but what happened to her 2019
crew have they returned to Navarro for
another semester have their injuries
healed without permanent damage or are
they attending new colleges and destined
to compete against their old team at the
2020 NCAA Championships
[Applause]
when we first meet Morgan simian are in
chair she's completing her second year
at Navarro College she's a dedicated
cheerleader whose spot in the national
championships isn't yet secured but
throughout the six episode docu-series
Morgan proves that she's an asset to the
team
the cheerleader ends up taking one of
her recently injured team members spots
in the championship and the rest is
cheer history but what happened to
Morgan once the camera stopped rolling
well for starters Morgan no longer
cheers for Navarro College she graduated
in May 2019 and cheered alongside her
teammates for the last time in November
today Morgan is living with her
grandparents in Texas and according to
her Instagram she could be attending
Texas Tech alongside two of her fellow
Navarro cheerleaders will reveal their
identities in just a few moments so keep
watching as for Morgan's love life she's
currently dating former Chicago Cubs
player Brad Marquis if I keep doing the
same things I keep cheering that if I
get hit in the ribs hard again they
could all fracture it it didn't take
long for cheer fans to fall in love with
Jeremiah Harris aka Jerry in fact it
only took one episode for him to become
a fan favorite like many of his fellow
cheerleaders Jerry had a heartbreaking
back story the athlete lost his mother
to cancer when he was just 16 years old
and he's worked twice as hard to stay
afloat ever since
Jerry's work ethic and positive vibes
are something to commiserate he never
gives up even when he doesn't make it to
the mat instead he supports his team
members who managed to land a spot in
the NCAA Championships in Daytona
Jerry's cheer mom started a GoFundMe
page to help him pay for school and
cheer which racked in around $40,000 at
the end of cheer Jerry was awarded a
scholarship at the University of
Louisville however it looks like he's
decided to come back to Navarro College
as of January 2020
ladarius Marshall has made it clear that
he never wants to struggle again
throughout the cheer documentary
ladarius revealed that he sees himself
having a family and living in the house
he's always dreamed of when we last
solid arias in the sixth episode
docu-series the senior squad member at
Navarro college was coaching at
Florida's zero-gravity athletics
however the talented athlete told the
cameras that when it came to his future
he didn't exactly have anything planned
when asked about what he'd like to do
the master tumbler expressed interest in
personal training choreography and the
US Army but according to his Instagram
account ladarius is living in Jackson
Mississippi and now refers to himself as
a cheerleader turned public figure
although ladarius has retired his
Navarro chair uniform he's optimistic
when it comes to his future the sky's
the limit for the talented young athlete
I wanted to really prove myself that I
was man enough to do it
Gabby Butler might just be the Navaro
cheerleader with the biggest online
following the cheer Liberty has always
had a lot on her plate some might even
say a little too much cheer viewers
quickly noticed that Gabby's parents
were super involved in her life and they
pointed this out online
the Gabby released a statement saying
that her parents have been nothing short
of amazing and supportive since filming
cheered Gabby has decided not to return
to Navaro college in US of 2020 gabby is
cheering for Top Gun 0:05 in Florida but
that's not all she's up to
obviously Gabby is still working on her
personal brand and modeling on her
Instagram account she also keeps herself
busy with her YouTube channel which she
recently relaunched as for Gabby's love
life she's currently dating football
player Jordan Brooks West what's your
major I'm like cheerleading
cheeri is quickly becoming one of the
most talked-about docu-series on Netflix
and for good reasons two people are
finally giving the sport the credit it
deserves after all cheerleading isn't
just about cute outfits and pom poms it
takes a lot of hard work dedication and
fearlessness to properly execute its
daring routines just ask Ally Roz ally
was given the chance to compete at the
NCAA championships when her teammate
herbs suffered an injury and although
perfecting the routine seemed impossible
at the time the top girl pushed her body
to its limits and nailed it as of 2020
Ally is still a proud member of the
Navarro cheerleading team but she's also
keeping busy by cheering with cheer
athletics when she's not preparing for
the 2020 NCAA Championships in Daytona
Ali spends time with her boyfriend
Dominic who cheer leads for Texas Tech
keep watching to find out how Lexi
Brumback managed to return to Navarro
college after getting kicked out at the
end of cheer
Monica Aldama might just be the best
cheer coach in the world but while she
loves her students she doesn't hold back
when they disrespect her orders and no
one knows this more than TT Barker you
know you messed up when Monica's alter
ego and net comes in swinging and that's
exactly what happened when titi competed
for another team against her orders only
to injure his back the two-time national
champion had to push through the pain
during rehearsals which wasn't an easy
thing to do while titi didn't have the
strongest storyline and cheer he's back
at Navarro College for a third year tt
took to Instagram to thank viewers for
their undying support and to let them
know that his back injury has finally
healed
[Music]
although indicus parent might not be a
member of the Navarro cheer team he is
one of the many people who made cheer
possible
he's Monica's right-hand man and without
him it would be hard to get everything
done right the first time on top of
working with Monica Andy is the owner of
cheer source Andy loves navarro College
almost as much as he loves teaching
students cheerleading's
January of 2020 Andy and the team
appeared on The Ellen Show where they
put on an unforgettable performance
[Music]
Jenna Woolsey was born in England but
raised in Texas where she quickly took a
liking to cheerleading she was known for
getting a little snarky throughout the
docu-series but it was nothing her
teammates couldn't handle
she used tough love to help her cheer
squad reach new heights and often sought
Morgan out just like Gabby Butler
Shannon has a large social media
following and she keeps herself busy by
being an Instagram influencer she
advertises everything from sportswear to
diet to workout apps and has a ton of
sponsored posts but even then her
content is bumping so fans just can't
help but follow her Shannon is a
two-time collegiate national champion
and although she has already been with
Navaro college for two years she'll
continue to cheer under Monica's
watchful eye for a third year in a row
without everybody coming together we're
gonna fail we're gonna fall mackenzie
Sherbourne knows a thing or two about
being injured in fact she revealed in
cheer that she had been concussed five
times Mackenzie who is better known as
sherbets a cheerleader at Navarro
College who is constantly being put in
precarious situations however her love
for the sport keeps her going no matter
how many bones she breaks the top girl
had viewers screaming when the spotters
missed their marks and failed to catch
her Erb suffered an arm injury which
cost her her spot on the mat but that
never stopped her from getting back on
the pyramid and doing what she loves
today Mackenzie is cheerleading for
Texas Tech alongside a few of her former
Navaro teammates her ribs are bruised
like I like I'm gonna go in for her
austin bails is one of those people who
is hard to forget he became a fan
favorite for his live-and-let-live
attitude as well as his powerful strut
and impressive floor work one of the
most devastating moments in cheer
happened when Austin injured himself in
the middle of nationals viewers couldn't
believe their eyes after all that hard
work after doing everything by the book
and coming out on top
Austin was unable to finish the routine
the Navarro cheer squad was forced to
stop midway through their performance
and start over which was heartbreaking
luckily Austin recovered and didn't
suffer any permanent damage today he's
cheerleading for Texas Tech alongside
his girl sure be responding them is what
makes you a better person a better
athlete it's what makes you succeed in
life okay who could forget about the
wonderful and hilarious James Thomas you
know the one who has this asking what
would a bad girl do James made watching
cheered that much more fun fans
especially loved james and jerry's
friendship and how they always lift each
other up where they belong the talented
stunter / tumbler debuted his rookie
season with a camera crew documenting
his every move and he was such a natural
today James continues to attend and
cheer for novaro college in January 2020
James appeared with the rest of the crew
for a special reunion on The Ellen Show
and last but certainly not least it's
Lexie Brumback the girl who proved that
there is no one template for
cheerleaders Lexie quickly became a fan
favorite due to her chill and
down-to-earth personality so fans were
devastated when it was revealed that
Lexie had been kicked off the team for
getting into too much trouble with the
law this was more than tragic as Lexie
came from a troubled background and had
previously revealed that cheers saved
her life
it was so upsetting to think that
someone as naturally gifted as Lexie
would miss out on such a huge
opportunity so fans were ecstatic when
they found out that Lexie was given a
second chance and allowed to return to
Navaro college for a second year but how
did Lexie managed to be led back in
well as it turns out like these parents
reached out to Monica and I asked her to
give their daughter another chance and
the coach obliged after all it isn't
every day that you find a female
cheerleader who can land a double full
and tumble like one of the boys and
that's a wrap
before you go tell us who your favorite
cheerleader from Netflix is chera is in
the comments section below thanks for
watching the things hit that subscribe
button for more and don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up I'll see you
next time
you